which types of systems are we modeling
well one more on all sorts of systems it
can be
some kind of propulsion system for a
marine application
it could be a robot or it could be an
aircraft or
an excavator so on so forth so it can be
a lot of different systems but what
we're looking at is the dynamics of the
systems
what happens when i uh
when i accelerate a car
or when i um when i take a drag
how would that metabolize in my body and
so on
so basically what happens over time when
i'm doing some
kind of action
see if my notebook works yep and
to accomplish that we have the part of a
visual
graphical user interface with a system
modeler which has
several different compo key features
that i will walk through like drag and
drop modeling multi-domain modeling
instant visualization and so on
and we also have a connection to
mathematica
so system understand alone from
mathematica and the first examples i
will give you
are completely independent of
mathematica but then
on the second half i will show examples
of
why would you like to connect to
mathematica what could you do
in case you have both of both
mathematica and
system modeler and i will as i said do
this by example so let's start by the
first example drag and drop modeling
why is this interesting so in
mathematica you you develop
code or let's see let me load the link
first
so in mathma as i will drive this from
mathematica
i'll need i have to learn to type
sorry
there we go
okay for some reason that would not open
up okay i know what i haven't loaded
library you have that
there you go
so um component based modeling
if we if we look at this model here
we have
we have two different representations of
the same model at the left hand side we
have an electrical circuit
as you would see it in a textbook at the
right hand side we have a block based
version of it
which is basically basically if you're
trying to represent the algorithm
in the terms of gains integrators and so
on
and this is basically what you what what
you would do
i don't know what it's kind of moving
here it's your phone perhaps
uh so so on the left hand side is
basically the algorithm you would
develop
if you would type it in in let's say c
code or anything like that
but on on the on the left hand side you
have the the electrical circuit
as you would have in textbook and also
as you have it in system modeler
you can simulate these two by us
clicking simulate here
um and without having to do any like
textual coding as you would do in
mathematica
it will simulate the two models and i
can go into any component
like the let's say the
sign the input voltage of my electrical
source and look at the current
it's like a sinusoidal current not very
spectacular but that's that's what you
have there
but i can also go to this block based
source and try to find the same
kind of same
current in that because this is the
representation of the other one
but of course it's harder for us to see
what is the current
of the resistor or the capacitor and so
on on the right hand
so it's kind of complicated to develop a
model in a block-based manner or in code
and then try to see it
so that's why we work with components
like this in this case
a resistor capacitor and so on
and it's important also that it's not
restricted to electrical fields so the
reason why
traditionally you were working in these
kind of let's say block based domains
was that you could do models of
different domains meaning it could be a
mechanical model
it could be a hydraulic model a
biochemical model and so on it didn't
really
matter because it was just a
mathematical representation
and then there was a bunch of tools
where you could do this left hand side
model electrical like spies which was
very good for some electric circuits and
so on
but you couldn't do kind of both a
general model and still be component
based
but that's what you can do in system
modeler so let's let's show a model
model some other type and let's go for a
pendulum
like that so in system mode there are
several different libraries available
with different types of components like
in
the modelica standard library that comes
with the software you can find
components from electrical components
mechanical
thermal and so on and in this case
i'll doing a pendulum and i will do a 3d
mechanical pendulum so i will use the
multi-body library which is a 3d
mechanical library
if i expand here there's a world object
and a world object is basically
let's assuming is basically
an object telling which is the
gravitation of
earth and so on i can set up my
environment basically
and then to this i will connect a joint
which let me use the simplest possible
revolute joint
and then to that one i will have
some kind of cylinder
connected to it so i go to the
let's say a body cylinder like that and
i can connect these together with a
connection line tool
so this is similar to how the the
electrical circuit was connected but
in this case it's a 3d mechanical system
now i can select different parts like
the body cylinder
and i will see a list of of parameters
describing it like
for instance r which is the length of it
i can set some length
one zero zero like that
and i have now set up my system yet
again behind the scenes we have
uh equations for this but we don't
really have to to bother we just have to
understand which are the types of
components that my system consists of
and then i can build that and simulate
and yes as for the electrical circuit i
can access all the vari
variables in each component like the
revolute joint the body cylinder
or in this case as a 3d mechanical
system
i will get in small visualization of the
pendulum
this kind of behaves in an expected way
then i can can you start expanding this
model let's say that i want to have a
a triple pendulum instead like make a
couple of copies of that
like that and i
really don't matter how i arrange things
here
i connect that so now i have
a similar system but with three
different
sections or three different pendulums
connected
to each other and i can simulate these
so i can start expanding making my
system more complicated as
i as i want to advance
and in this case the system would
have three pendulums connected to each
other and as i have not added any kind
of
friction models or anything like that we
will see it behaving
in a chaotic manner okay
so what happens if i for instance
if in fact i have some friction then i
want to add that
so how do i add friction to this model
well i can do that by
connecting a friction model to every
joint
i can do that i'll add a flange here so
i can connect things
say true here and we can see that it
pops up two
small connectors here and that our
connection to rotational mechanics
so now i can connect components from the
rotational mechanics library
like a damper which is basically
friction
like this
or i might perhaps want to add
some actuation to this one so let's
change that also
let's say how would i activate that okay
so let's do this
we'll see more of this library in next
presentation but it's
a hydraulic library that we have added
um
where we have let's see if we have
examples of rotational actuators
there you go
let's look at this one uh yeah probably
a good one
so this is a hydrostatic transmission
doesn't really matter
what it is let's let me create a copy of
that and try to use just to show
how i can can connect things together i
copy that to my use classes
so this is a hydro static transmission
we won't go through the details of it
there's no time for that
but what i'll do is i'll add a
connection here
at the output side of my transmission
create connector and that means now if i
use this in the pendulum
like this i didn't really place the
connector very well
i can connect the transmission to my
joint here
so now i have connected hydraulic
circuit to my mechanical
circuit and that will hopefully activate
hopefully
i'm not sure it will hopefully oh
work so now i can simulate this
it says optimizing equations so this is
basically when it's generating the code
that you would otherwise have to do by
hand if you would
like to code it in in for instance in
mathematica
and now we can go and look at the
simulation of this
and hopefully it looks slightly
different from
from the previous version
and i forgot to set any any parameter
for the frictions or friction is
probably serum
or or low but still you see that so that
it behaves quite differently
so that easily can add different uh
different uh parts whether it's friction
hydraulic actuation or whatever partial
yeah the hydraulic system as i just
grabbed an example that was ready-made
probably all parameters are set there i
really didn't don't know anything i just
grabbed
an example that i haven't looked at
before so um
it has parameters set for every for
all the valves and and so on in it
okay so that's that's the the the most
important feature of of system order to
be able to drag and drop things together
and then that means you can do
multi-domain models so you can combine
as you saw the hydraulic circuit with
mechanical circuit
it could be electrical activator and so
on and so forth
and to help with that you had a built-in
model libraries
where where you have components that you
can reuse rather than having to
build components yourself
and also as we're
building up so in this case i added
uh i can actually as i as i did it this
way i can actually
illustrate hierarchical in this sense
means that now we have the example model
there
that i use reused and that is used as
one component so i double click into
that
and i can see this is the system i'm
using
here so hierarchically i'm building up a
system
with components that become more and
more complex this system that i built
here might be
another component that i add to another
system to make it something even larger
so hierarchically i can build up a very
advanced system
i think i skipped that for time
constraint
and of course
the model itself is not that interesting
what makes the model interesting
is once you start to analyze it
so it could be a simple model like this
one one which is a
model of a wheel so wheels are
people how we have used wheels for
thousands of years but still they're
complicated to understand
and even this kind of simple example
where we have a wheel here this is the
wheel
and then we apply a constant torque on
it
and it's attached to a center here with
a revolute joint
and can basically rotate around that and
when
the centrifugal force becomes too big
then it will become start to slide
so let's look at this how how this looks
like so so this is what we would like to
study
what how would this behave when we apply
this force
and it might be expected
things or less expected so in this case
what i will do is i will plot
the position of the
uh wheel take the drive will friction
see here and choose the
it was there and
was that really where i wanted to go
let's close a little bit here
close all about this no
uh oh actually i should go to the
let's look at the model again it's the
prismatic joint
frame a i guess an x
and y oh that's that's of course the
frame b
should be there one there you go
so now what we can see is how the wheel
is uh because of of
how the axis simply shows in here that
doesn't look like a circle but it's a
circle
and we can see that in the beginning we
have the wheel
revoluting in more or less a fixed
radius
and then after a while it slips out
and goes here and actually if i simulate
for a longer time
let's go for 40 seconds or
60 seconds
i will see that it repeats this behavior
actually
so now i can start to experiment and try
to understand why is this happening
anybody knows
no so so yeah so basically when it's
going out
out here the centrifugal force is
going down so after a while if we will
be lower
then it will be low enough
so that the frictional force will be
high enough to keep the wheel without
sliding
but then it will start accelerating
again because of this constant torque
and after a while it will slip
it's kind of i would guess it's similar
to what happens when you drive
aggressively
with your car i really don't know but it
feels like it's kind of
relates to that
so in a sense that's that's that's all
you want to do in system r you want to
build a model whether that's as in this
example
a mechanical model or a biochemical
model model
you drag and drop that together and you
do some plots
and for that you use the built-in
libraries or you create your own
custom libraries i think i will skip
that
but basically how you have the hydraulic
component there
you can make your own versions your own
components and reuse them
in larger systems
and upon that we will have extra
libraries that are not included in the
software itself but
that you can download from a library
store
and there the hydraulic library that i
use was one of those examples
there's a biochem library a cooling
library and so on and actually
it's i think i will return to that in
the next as
the library store is a new thing but
today we had a new library called model
plug
that we we launched but i'll get back to
that in next session
so that is what you use system model for
and now you have have done this
you can look at the plots you can change
parameters and see what what happens
if i change the friction how would the
how would the would the system
change and so on but then
why would you have mathematica well
mathematic is there for several reasons
and for instance to programmatically
create simulations rather than running
the simulation as a different simulation
center
i can use it as as usual from from
mathematics okay that was
i that link was not correct um let's
skip that let's go here instead and
we will gain some time also on that so
basically you can do
things like running batch simulations
from from within mathematica
saying yeah like any mathematic code you
you can have
but there's a wsm simulate command let's
try to find it instead i don't know why
that link didn't work
let's go here
where would i have that it's probably
there yeah
it's easier to understand what what you
would be doing so
you you would have something like uh
having a a c a model within mathematica
and run wsm simulate which is wall from
system auto simulate
and you can change things like in this
case initial value
setting that to range rather than a
specific initial value
or you can change parameters to arrange
or you can program that
in any way you would like so so within
mathematica set up
the kind of simulations you want to do
whether you want to do a monte carlo
simulation or what what you would like
to do
and then get results within the
mathematical environment so here you
will
see a plot of a bouncing ball
when we release it from different
heights
so very simple but it allows you to do a
lot of experimentation
rather than in in like a command line
rather than having to
try different parameters one after the
other
you can also use it for control design
um i have very little
limit of time so i'll go rather than
showing there it could be model
inversion control so you would would
like to
did a loose internet connection rather
rather than developing yeah
okay so let's go back here uh
so rather than when you develop the
model you want to have develop a
controller
so you had a model then you can go to
deploy the model into
into mathematica and use mathematics
control system
capabilities to design the control
system and then deploy that to the model
back to the model and you have a model
that will behave the way you like
so so you might do something like this
where you have
a system if in case you happen to know
model inversion control is you have a
model
that rather than so you build a model of
the system
and then you look which is the desired
output you invert your model and set
that output as the input of your system
and you will see which is the which is
the input that replicates
what i would like to and then i can
apply the input to my real system
to control that and get my behavior and
this is one thing where you could use
mathematica for
so if we go back to the dry friction as
you saw that rapidly you can do
i skipped through a bunch of things it
was sensitivity analysis model
calibration model optimization
all sorts of things that you would
normally do in mathematica you can do
now with the models
so that's the idea you could do things
like more plot custom visualizations
and plots of your system so if we go
back to the dry friction
and look at that model from a
on the website here we can see we have
this system here
and you can create small
cdfs like this one where you can study
how does this
behave so you remember the plot at the
wheel position
now this is the the friction curve where
the slip velocity
is the x-axis and the friction force is
the y-axis and that's
how the friction works for for well
different wheels have different
frictions but in this case this is the
model for the for the friction
and using this we can now start to
play around here and see that when we
move here in time we see we're
in here and that's at the same time you
can see that the point here
the velocity uh or slip velocity is
below a threshold here
and we can follow the point in all of
these we are in this green area here and
it's when we come to this
orange area let's see if i can hit that
like here oh it was
somewhere here in the orange area where
i start i will start to slip
because that's where my slip force will
see it it kind of decreases
as the slip velocity increases
and as the slip force decreases we will
lose traction
at the same time the centripetal force
is increasing slowly
and we will get into this part where we
where we sleep here until we reach
a point where the force centripetal
force
is larger or smaller than the certain
than
than the friction force and will yet
again start to
revolute in a constant manner and then
we will slip again
so on
so
mathematica i gave a very
quick part of that mathematic is used to
analyze your system to design it
and to explore ideas system motor
is used to develop the system itself and
do initial
investigations of it basically doing
plots doing
3d visualizations and so on and
understanding better how it works
so with that i'll leave for questions
thank you